[Music]
hi good afternoon everybody thank you
for joining us today for the session
from blobs to tables where to store your
data my name is Dave nettleton I'm a
product manager at Google looking after
some of the storage products there and
joined by my colleague Robert sacks me
Saxby who's a big data specialist flown
in specially from Amsterdam for the for
the event so let's let's get started so
what we're gonna go through today is an
overview of the different products that
we have in GCP for storing your data and
there's a fairly reasonable selection of
those products and so what I wanted to
do before it's sort of diving into the
name of the product and you know what it
does and why it's awesome I wanted to
sort of step back a little bit and go
through a bit of sort of historical
context as to you know so where did all
these products come from and why all
right so what Google go through that
will go through the products talk a
little bit about when to use them what
use cases and how to think about them
and then Robert spends all his time
working deeply with customers on
architectures and solutions out there in
the field and he'll go through some some
of the sort of canonical patterns that
we see that you might want to think
about for your for your applications and
then we'll end I will try to leave a
good sort of five or ten minutes at the
end for Q&A great so let's dive in so
let's go through the storage the history
of storage and database products so if I
go kind of all the way back from a
storage point of view you know
originally when you attach storage to
machines it was physically attached so
this is direct it's called direct
attached storage we take a hard disk you
physically attach it to a computer and
that's the storage that that computer
has available to it
the application the filesystem the
storage they're all on a single
machine a single device that your
application runs on
so obviously this has a lot of
limitations but it's kind of kind of
where things started and these obviously
still exist today so direct-attached
storage
physically attached to the device
obviously you start to run into some
limitations with this like huh what I'm
if I need more storage what happens if I
need to share my storage between servers
what do i do then so this is where then
you now need to sort of think about
where is my compute where is my storage
and what role is the network playing in
connecting these together and to two
different models I emerged here one is a
storage area network or a SAN what this
lets you do is it lets you move the
underlying our block storage off of the
machine and put it into a shared piece
of hardware that often offers really
great performance tearing between
different classes of storage whether
it's SSD devices or hard disks but the
the file system and the application is
still living on on on the server or the
other clients and so you can't really
share that storage between different
applications or between different
computers because the file system that's
operating it is still out there in that
in that server so another alternative is
their network attached storage and in
this model you know one of the most
common examples is something like a file
share
so here the the server is a file share
server you mounted over the network so
you would go into your operating system
you'd found two directory or you'd mount
a share over the network and the
filesystem is remote from your computer
over the network and what that lets you
do is then now start to share files
between many different computers so if
you know two to two clients want to
operate over a shared directory in a
file share they can do it by using
Anna's solution to do that and then the
these are the probably the most to
common and actually still today in an
enterprise on-premises IT infrastructure
these are the most common forms of
storage did you'll see
and more recently object storage really
started to emerge as as a third form of
storage for when you have really large
amounts of unstructured storage media
files or other assets that don't need
the super high performance and often
costly solutions that are often provided
by sands and nas but gives you sort of
low cost large object storage and these
solutions so all of these solutions
available in in the in enterprises and
then as you look at the cloud the
products that your map to and you'll
hear me talking about today for block
storage persistent disk in both standard
and SSD versions and local SSD so this
is our block storage product for
attaching to VMs for network just at
storage so for a file system we
announced recently as recently as last
month
a cloud file store which is now in beta
which is a file storage product for NAS
solutions we also have great
partnerships with net a PMC elastic file
who are also offering their solutions as
part of GCP and then for object storage
you'll hear me talk about cloud storage
is our object storage solution maybe one
thing to note actually in the cloud
object storage actually sort of took off
disproportionately to the on-premises
use case which is kind of an intravenous
started to bring storage to the cloud
actually many of them started with
object storage solutions and so there's
the object storage use cases are sort of
really ballooned with with the cloud so
this is the sort of the evolution of the
different various storage products it's
all really to do is like where's my file
system where as the data and where's the
network all right we'll come back to
that the importance of the network in
this a couple of times through the talk
all right
databases a little trickier so so the
world of databases was super easy for 20
or 30 years the idea of a relational
database model where you have tables
relationships between those databases
you'd run your transactional system your
banking system against that database and
if you ever needed to do reporting or
analytics on it you know typically these
systems were scale up actually often
quite expensive didn't necessarily store
a huge amount of data because of sort of
the cost and scale and if you wanted to
run reporting and analytics queries
against them you really didn't want to
run that report in query against the
system that's doing your you know
transactional records or system of
record for your bank so what you would
typically do is you would go through a
process called ETL so extract transform
load you would lift up some a copy of
the data and you'd put it in something
called a data warehouse in the data
warehouse was a system specifically
designed for high performance queries
that aggregated large amounts of data so
in the process of moving the data from
your you know orders and records and
customers table you'd move it over to a
data warehouse you transform the data in
a way that met the needs of the queries
that you were going to run against it
and that's where you would run your
reports and analytics from and you know
there was various you know OLAP and
other technologies that came along to
help accelerate that and make that super
efficient and for you know 20 30 years
you know major on Preta your Oracle
Microsoft IBM you know build huge huge
businesses out of this ecosystem and for
30 years that was that was good enough
um and about 10 15 years ago a whole
bunch of things started to happen that
caused a lot of chaos confusion made
choices for you all harder right
and so what so what happened well
through you know as the world became
more connected the Internet emerged IOT
emerged the amount of data that's
getting generated and that there's an
opportunity to derive value from just
exploded I mean and you know if it's
media assets and other things you might
put them into object storage systems and
serve them but if you want to start to
do analytics over log files another you
know really large semi structured or
unstructured data there really wasn't an
analytics alternative for you if you put
it in your warehouse it wasn't a really
super well design for that and it
certainly didn't you know from a cost
point of view it would get pretty
prohibitively expensive pretty quickly
and so so actually Google some time ago
introduced this paradigm called
MapReduce which basically said look drop
all of your unstructured data into just
the cheapest form of storage possible
storing large amounts of it and then run
jobs against that to sort of refine that
data and structure it you know count
words in it or look through logs for
clique patterns nowadays and it
introduced a framework called MapReduce
around that I was popularized into the
Hadoop open source project companies
like cottonwoods map our cloud era took
that further and made commercial
distributions around that and so so for
a while there's this interesting
dichotomy in the analytics industry you
know the the big data vendors would say
throw away your data warehouse you don't
need it anymore do everything in in the
big data systems and the data warehouse
folks were all very confused going what
what I don't know why are they saying
that you don't need those systems just
put it all in your warehouse so that
sort of played out over a couple of
years fortunately now everything sit
probably seems to settle down and
everyone recognizes that these are sort
of complementary systems so data lakes
great for gathering and aggregating
large amounts of data then when you want
to serve it for very particular
analytics use cases and all becomes more
structured and a data warehouse fits in
well so that's the analytics part of the
world in terms of storing records of
data though this whole other paradigm
emerged called no sequel and again a
couple of
of patterns that have driven that will
use cases where hey I've got you know
devices sending me back huge amounts of
data I don't really know this columns
that I'm gonna have for that data in
advance they might change or the data is
going to be very sparse you know you
couldn't store some of that and go
actually got quite a long way with a
traditional relational world database
management system but it sort of became
clunky and a bit sort of overpowered in
some areas and underpowered in other
places so so for something like you know
large key value stores that was a whole
other class of kind of no sequel
[Music]
products that emerged another pattern is
JSON document so if you have customer
catalogs or other things where there's a
sort of a hierarchical structure to the
data as opposed to tabular structure to
the data you could just kind of hard
like round peg square hole to model add
into a database so a specific class of
no sequel databases emerged out of that
and then the other thing with a regular
databases it's kind of hard to scale
they scale up pretty well scaling them
out is really hard so there's now with
the sort of bleeding edge and and Google
has some of these products to really
help customers now scale their databases
beyond the traditional confines of what
they're being able to do so these are
being sorted I'll talk to some of the
specifics of the products we have on
this all in US in a second but I just
sort of wanted to take you a little bit
on the journey of where these came from
and you know they're actually all still
evolving as they go forward so as I look
across all the different products that
are out there you can see some of the
some of these starting to blend and
merge so be prepared for a little bit of
that but but there's a very powerful set
of products now that a much more niche
to use case it used to be our DBMS
hammer hit use that in all cases there's
actually more choice now in terms of
what you can do with the products and
the benefit you can get from them so let
me start to go through some of their
products and a little bit more detail so
this is the overall portfolio that we
have
for GCP so all the way I'll start on the
right so object file and block products
cloud storage persistent disk file store
our data warehouse product is bigquery
from the database side relational and no
sequel cloud sequel spanner data store
BigTable and then for caching in memory
cloud memory store go through each of
these in a bit more detail before I do
that though you know one of the things
that is another sort of trend that has
emerged is this ability to separate
storage and compute you're one of the
reasons storage and compute need to be
often tied together is it's obviously
just for a performance right you want to
keep you if you if your storage and
compute is co-located you get much
better performance that often means then
it's needed to be physically co-located
often on to the same machine one of the
big things that I love about Google's
product lineup is we've invested so
deeply in either the network capability
both wide area network like you might
have heard Brad talked about in this
morning's keynote but also in data
center network the network within a data
center that in that our products can we
can actually separate storage and
compute from each other physically and
actually not have it really affect
performance in a meaningful way and and
one of the things that this really
fundamentally lets you achieve is you
can scale storage separate from compute
alright and this is a fundamentally
important capability that lets you
really think about in design systems in
a different way particularly in the like
data and analytics world if you can just
gather and store gigantic amounts of
data and storage without having to size
compute as you go along with it even if
you don't know how much of it you're
going to use it's a very very powerful
paradigm and then across all our
products that's one thing that we've
done consistently separate storage from
computing it actually means that the
products that we can offer tend to then
be fundamentally simpler because we make
that that effectively a very a seamless
experience for you I mean let me dive in
a little bit more on the products ok so
cloud storage so so this is our
basically our fully managed object
storage system
very classic use cases here is I want to
store and serve media so videos images I
want to store them serve them I might
want to back up our archive large
amounts of data or I might want to
create a data Lake install large amounts
of data for data processing and bring a
selection of analytics products to bear
on top of that used across a whole bunch
of verticals media mobile financial
services health care we see this product
use very broadly across the across the
board some of the key features about
this product so we offer four different
storage classes so you can choose to
location types multi regional or
regional storage and from there you can
then tear the data down into what we
call knee align and cold line so this
gives you the ability to have data
that's hot available to serve
immediately
but tear it down to cold cheaper classes
of storage if you don't need to access
it very often and one thing that's very
unique about this product is we give you
a single API across all those different
storage classes so once you put an
object into Google Cloud storage and you
get an object ID behind the scenes you
can change the storage class and you can
put it in our coldest class of storage
cold line the object ID doesn't change
and more importantly if you ever need to
access that data your performance in
terms of accessing it doesn't change
either so you basically get instant
access to your cold archive data which
is very unique in the industry and a
super powerful model for when you're
building applications because now you
can just build your application once and
not worry about the storage that its
class of it's stored in and manage the
cost and access to that storage separate
from the application so single API
across all storage classes millisecond
access to the first byte of data and
takes advantage of our wide area network
to both bring data into the platform as
well as to serve content out so there's
edge caching built in and then another
super important feature here is
consistency strong consistency so when
you write an object into Google Cloud
storage
it's immediately available for all
of compute instances or analytics
instances to see it immediately and and
operate over it I'll talk a little bit
more about strong and eventual
consistency but strong consistency is
super important for analytics workloads
when you've got multiple compute
instances reading and writing against a
single bucket they all see the same view
of the data and that's a pretty big deal
for analytics workloads that's Google
Cloud Storage persistent disk so this is
the classic I'm running a VM I'm I'm
using containers and I need a disk so
the disk that we provide you don't like
it's not like a physical disks that's
actually on the same server in our data
centers it's actually over the network
we create you effectively a virtual disk
that you can then attach to these
instances we provide it as a single
zonal product and then we've just also
recently announced a beta of what we
call regional persistent disk which
actually replicates synchronously the
data between two zones within a region
which is super important for workloads
like databases where you might want to
think about height high availability and
failover of the database instance so
again we make this super simple to use
we offer two tiers standard and
high-performance tiers with a single
disk you can scale it dynamically up to
64 terabytes and we're announcing at
this event that you can go up to 60,000
I ops on that and again one thing that's
super interesting super unique here is
you don't need to stripe your disks to
get the maximum performance out of the
VM so classic on-premises IT
infrastructure you attach multiple disks
you set up striping raid and other
things from an IT administration point
of view to get the the behavior that you
want you don't need to do any of that
with persistent disk on on GCP we take
care of all of that behind the scenes
for you you just create a single this
you run all your workloads we balance
all of the operations against it
and
and then let you seamlessly scale it up
to the maximum performance of the VM we
also have management operations like
being able to take snapshots against the
data you can also take these disks and
attach them for to multiple VMs in
read-only mode for often sharing data so
again it's super simple super powerful
easy to use product is what we're aiming
for here with a persistent desk for
block storage our file store so cloud
file store so if you remember earlier I
was talking about the different ways you
might want to access storage effectively
over the network and how you think about
that you know lots of applications have
been written with file storage in mind
so this is you know file shares or or
I'm doing video and image editing in my
organization I no need to share files
between them or often or I maybe once
I've done some manipulation of various
image files I want to do some rendering
in a render farm and I need lots of
compute to access those those files or
just general sort of web applications
like WordPress they all operate on this
model of a basically a shared file
system so with cloud file store this
gives us that gives customers now a
fully managed network attached file
storage again standard and performance
tiers we've focused very much on making
it easy simple to use from both a price
and performance point of view integrate
it well with GCE and gke and give really
just good solid consistent I ops and and
performance so this is now in beta we
announced it about a month ago
all right over to the world of databases
so I wondered how far to go here you
know acid properties cap theorem you
know all the kind of things you want in
an intro talk on where to store storage
but I thought I'd better hit a couple of
the concepts just because I'll can't
help talk about them later and so
traditional relational database
management system you know you create
tables of data
and they have defined columns and then
you set constraints foreign keys for
example between them because you want to
do things like if I've got a savings you
know if I'm a bank and a customers have
multiple accounts with me and I want to
deduct you know dollars from my savings
account and put it in my checking
account I got to make multiple
operations on multiple rows at the same
time and I want to make sure that when I
do that like the whole thing all happens
together even though it's happening
across different tables so that's called
a transaction transactions have
particular properties acid properties
atomic you know if I'm moving data
between two accounts all of those
operations need to happen at the same
time right so it's atomic they all
happen together consistent I'm
guaranteed that when the operation
completes I leave the the multiple
tables and the overall model of the
database in a consistent state isolated
means if you're if several operations
are writing transactions at the same
time then they won't interfere with
other and durable says that you know
once you act back that that operation is
complete it really really is complete
even if the system dies it guarantees
that being able to recover to that point
in time so the so this is the sort of
the classic properties of transactions
and you know I talked a little bit
earlier about as no sequel solutions
have come along some of the some of the
trade-offs that they've made and one of
the big things is I think about you know
really wide columns or document storage
they frankly often don't need all of
those capabilities and so we're willing
to make some trade-offs and one of the
most fundamental trade-offs they often
make is between strong and eventual
consistency you just kind of confuse
things this is a different type of
consistency than the consistency in on
the web so strongly eventual consistency
means as I'm writing data in whoever
reads it is guaranteed to see the latest
version so strong consistency says every
time something's written all of the
readers see the latest version of of the
of the object with eventual consistency
it means eventually everybody will see
the latest version but not immediately
and
that might sound weird but there's some
use cases where if I'm you know
following how many people like or follow
me on Twitter or something whether it's
fifty thousand or fifty thousand and one
I don't really care so long as it's
really fast and
you know good enough results quickly
right so I'm willing to make some
trade-offs on accuracy but if I'm you
know making looking at banking records I
don't want to like no thank you I really
want to know that what I'm looking at is
the latest copy of the data thank you
very much
so no sequel systems have made some of
these trade-offs and I'll talk about the
products a little bit from that context
so let me start with just the relational
database management systems so cloud
sequel is our is our product fully
managed for fully managed third party
relational DB's so if you're using my
sequel if you're using Postgres if
you're if you a kind of sick of dealing
with underlying storage concepts of
replication clustering and failover then
cloud sequel is the product for you
gives you all of the acid transactions
at the database level that you'd be
familiar with with an our DBMS system
but gets you out of the out of having to
manage the underlying backends to deal
with high availability backup security
updates gets you out of the
infrastructure management and focus on
the higher-level values of their app you
can of course take my sequel and run it
in
GCE VM and attach a disk to it and do
this yourself if you want but with cloud
sequel and we let you worry less about
managing and keeping that service
running and focus on the high level
application so you know used for all of
the classic examples that you would
expect or a good old relational database
management system to be to be useful one
interesting thing with most relational
database management systems is they're
basically what I would call scale-up
systems right so if you want more
transactions if you want more storage
you can't have to just keep building a
bigger and bigger and bigger system you
know H
for many years would build bigger and
bigger super domes and other gigantic
systems basically to run really really
really really big databases and the
reason they did that is it's really hard
to scale out a database because as soon
as you scale out a database you end up
with data in multiple places and
remember in a relational database
management system you know you want to
keep a consistent view of the entire
database so you got rows you've got
tables but the unit of consistency from
an asset point of view is an entire
database and as that scales out it
becomes very very challenging to to
manage that in fact there's a you know
the cap theorem basically tells you you
get to pick between consistency
availability and ability to partition
and you only get to pick two out of the
three right so so one of the things
we've built at Google we build it
internally to deal with this problem was
a product called cloud spanner and as
you scale your systems up from an our
DBMS perspective you imagine you'd want
to deal with like a global inventory
system and you've got you know systems
all around the world managing inventory
but you want a single common global
global inventory system you know what
customers would typically start to do is
they'd start to manage and build and
shard and come up with these complex
application constructs to effectively
shard out there are DBMS solution so be
it it would be you know one application
but there are five different database
servers that we're dealing with
different parts of it and they'd run it
at the edge condition it just becomes
horrible and gnarly and messy if you've
ever tried it I feel you know good job
because it's really really hard to do
and you can wire it together to work for
particular applications but it's just
not where you want to be spending your
time so what we've done with cloud
spanner is actually build a fully
managed relational database system that
can do transactions at the database
level at a global scale and the thing
that we've done that's really unique is
like you have to make some trade off
right and what we've done is you know by
using
and you know this is fascinating story
atomic clocks and something called true
time we've made it so that the the
trade-off on availability is so tiny
that it doesn't matter from an
application point of view to all intents
and purposes right so you get a fully
consistent database we've partitioned it
across the world and we've used atomic
clocks to get synchronization so tight
but we can still give like a five nines
availability SLA over this data so this
is an incredibly powerful relational
database management system that we've
been using to run some of the largest
systems inside of Google and really
excited to see what customers are going
to do with this this was just baited a
year ago GA now so seeing some super
interesting it pick up on this one all
right a big table okay so that was
relational database management systems
now let me switch over to sort of the no
sequel world so let me start with
BigTable so here I want to I want to
store lots of records with you know very
wide columns so I might have tens
hundreds thousands tens of thousands of
different columns that I might want not
all the data is going to have all
columns it's going to be very sparsely
populated it's not very efficient to
pack that into a relational database and
and the thing that I care about is like
the the unit of atomicity remember in a
database it's you know you got rows and
tables and the entire database in a big
in in in a wide column database like
BigTable really you're only getting
atomic operations at the row level right
so you know you don't like you don't get
my foreign key relationships or anything
fancy like that what you get is the
ability to write and read row level data
incredibly quickly so this has it you
know single-digit millisecond reads and
writes and and the trade-off there is if
you want to read all of that data
you know it's eventually consistent so
it's good for sort of big aggregate type
operations and if you've been using
something like Cassandra or HBase which
have really large amounts of data and
you're having trouble scaling those
clusters then we have a HBase compatible
API that lets you very easily move those
applications across to
run over big table really great for sort
of real-time analytics workloads
building out monitoring time series IOT
datasets next so if I now move from like
hey I care about an individual row to I
have now a document like structure for
user profiles messaging product catalogs
typically I'm dealing with sort of a
JSON structure where I've got a tree of
data and what I get what I want to deal
with here is I want a certain amount of
you know transactional support it
doesn't need to be over my entire system
but I'm gonna get it over a subset of my
data and eventual consistency is okay
and this is where the current data store
product is and if you look at products
to compare with out there if I'm running
MongoDB or Couchbase then I'm running
those clusters you know this is a fully
managed version of that so now you
wouldn't need to worry about managing
the clusters if you switch over to using
data store there's a couple of other
things in this on this page which I'll
highlight now so so at this event we're
talking about how we're going to move
from what we call data store of sort of
second-generation product here we're
going to be moving to what we call a
third-generation product in fire store
so there's a little asterisks there so
you'll see we have something called
cloud fire store announced what we're
gonna do is actually will carry forward
data store you know completely backwards
compatible within that but we're
actually gonna bring even more sort of
underlying power to it so you can still
use that document data model but we're
going to remove some of the restrictions
that you have with with it today so
you'll be able to do transactional
support across the entire store and
we'll move four in from an eventual to
strong consistency model for this as
well so remember saying earlier the
world of no sequel database is
continuing to evolve evolution in
in progress right here the key thing
here is you know your data model is much
more of a document structured data model
all right memory starts so great for
storing all of your data in through a
whole bunch of stars there now I just
want to make my application go really
really really fast so you might use
something like Redis for this already
we offer basically a fully managed
version of that memory store so you can
now cache data in memory to give you
millisecond lookups for that data from
your application of course it's not
persistent the persistence is in the
stores I've already talked about but
super fast to accelerate a bunch of your
workloads bigquery so talks a lot about
regular storage databases and now data
warehouse so bigquery is our massively
scalable data warehouse will code you
can store gigabytes to exabytes the data
in in this running really large scale
analytics over it
this was I've been with Google nearly
two years now this is one of my favorite
internal products when I got here you
know I was looking around and querying
like who's using what in the products so
I write a query I run it you know 15 20
seconds later a results set comes back
and like oh that's cool like how much
how much day-to-day just query you know
like you know do account selects that's
like you know several billion records
I'm like yeah that's pretty cool
so so you know so this is the you know
really scalable powerful data warehouse
product that we have it has an optimized
column the storage format that we manage
on your behalf to just make it work
really fast you can stream data in at a
really fast rate whilst querying it at
the same time we just announced in the
keynote today that you can actually now
build Enel models directly in bigquery
without leaving bigquery this is a
really big deal it's really hard for
people to do data science this just
makes it easier to build models so that
your organization can start to leverage
them right from within the tool that
you're already using so this is great
used across very many workloads often as
a complement to something like a data
Lake where I'm storing large amounts of
unstructured data for serving
and for building you know the classic
sort of data warehouse solution on GC P
and I think with that I'm gonna hand
over to Robert who will take it away so
now we've gone through all the storages
I guess like everyone else we all know
which storage to pick now that's it
we're done so if you know which storage
to pick then that was the end of the
talk if you're like me and many
customers I've worked with and you think
oh right I get it now this is what I'm
gonna use and then someone comes up to
you but we try to use this product well
hopefully we're going to try and tackle
some of that now and provide a little
bit more context of how to choose which
storage and there are different use
cases we're going to look at I mean some
of these are more of a lift and shift
type of use case and some of them are
going to be more of the next generation
of application let me just grab hold of
this or even this one there we go so the
first the first couple I'll show you our
more of a lift and shift type nature so
one news case or one expansion into the
cloud that we see even if we're not
talking about applications or different
workloads
it's basically archiving data disaster
recovery and you know just making that
data available for some other use case
somewhere else later so in this
particular class of use case it's
basically how do we get data from
on-premise to the cloud so the typical
place where this data lands is Google
Cloud Storage as Dave pointed out is
object storage
it's the durability is something like 11
9 so you don't have to worry about
backing that data out there this is
highly durable storage so things that
you might want to do here it's like okay
if I'm going to use it for an archive
you know how often do I actually go and
access that data so as they point out we
have different tiers for pricing there
and a single API so this makes it all
good but then the next question is how
do I get my data there so to get your
data to Google Cloud Storage we provide
utilities like gsutil which I'm sure
some
forty years we had the transfer service
which is for scheduling larger lows and
you can you know check the like hash
codes that you're actually reading the
right story at the right objects you
know the bringing the right things
across and we have a whole bunch of
partners out there and I've just really
put a few of them up here just to kind
of illustrate the point they're really
operate in the different area so
ingesting data helping provide solutions
that back up and do disaster recovery so
you know getting your data somewhere but
then getting it back again as well and
obviously in that middle category you're
also thinking what application am I
taking the data from so you might not be
on-premise reading it from object
storage you might be reading it from an
ass you might be reading it from a
database system so how do I get that
storage out you might be reading logs
how do I get that storage out into the
cloud so I know I've got my backup of
premise now I know I've got a disaster
recovery plan and I could start
archiving as well you know I can start
storing maybe less data on premise so
these are some of the things that you
can consider with using Google Cloud
storage and that typically tends to be
the storage medium that's used in this
case so the next one is a bit more
complicated because they're just
basically gone horizontal on on all the
different types of storage we have here
so let's look actually I were we're
having the conversation we'll be putting
this together we were trying to define
what is lift and shift and it came very
clear to us that there were two actual
types of lift and shift one is the Rijo
stting and the other is a refactoring
now INRI hosting you have an application
it runs the sale Windows or on Linux and
you want to run the application in the
cloud now that application require story
so if you wanted to move for example
that my sequence you want to do you're
in your operation yourself you want to
take care of the maintenance yourself
because if specific requirements or you
know the slightly different for we
providing them a new service or you've
got another application that we don't
have a managed service for then you
would move that application you know
across into the cloud or on it on a VM
you could run that in a container if it
was really containerized but you know
classically this tends to be going into
a VM and then you've got to pick what
type of storage do you want underneath
so the storage in this case the two that
you could look at are both like you know
POSIX block storage you would say either
a local disk or if you want to share
that amongst multiple instances like
have high availability when you're
running that my sequel if you're going
to have that in two different zones and
then you would look at the the Nass
stories that we provide and again there
are partner solutions for the NASS as
well and that might be because you
already using that partner solution
on-premise and it would be a very
natural transition to use that in the
cloud as well using the same API as you
do gathering the same kind of metrics so
the lift and refactor essentially this
is a kind of lift and shift story we're
saying right I'm going to move across
but I'm going to be using something a
little bit different underneath because
I need some different capability so let
me give you an example we start first of
all with HBase so HBase typically runs
on Hadoop cluster when you want to scale
your HBase then you scale your Hadoop
cluster you scale the storage is to be
all the compute HBase will give you
something like if you think given a good
key strategy so you're not hot spotting
your keys you'll get maybe ten to seven
well somewhat above tens probably in
like 60 to 70 milliseconds of latency to
the first byte with BigTable which would
be our and and just for the record HBase
Cassandra based on that original
BigTable paper so BigTable will give you
if you do properly six milliseconds of
latency it's a top it's atomic at the
row so you have strong consistency at
the row level you can now replicate your
BigTable into multiple zones and then
you would have eventual consistency
between those two instances but this
thing is linearly scalable which is
quite a hard thing to do on your HBase
cluster linear scalable means that if I
have ten thousand IELTS or I want to go
all that we have customers literally in
the hundreds of thousand queries per
second I said I upped some inquiries per
second sorry hundreds of thousands of
queries per second at six milliseconds
latency across their database this thing
is like yeah rocket fuel
that's great how do I use it now with my
existing product
well we actually provide a HBase
compliant API so the storage is quite
different it gives you some different
capabilities it's much faster you can
scale it linearly but you have the same
API so that re hosting of your
application becomes quite simple another
example this is Hadoop so if you're
moving from Hadoop then you know you're
using HDFS again you want to decouple
this you wanna you wanna the benefit
that you being with scale your storage
independently of your compute we would
recommend using object storage now there
are a few limitations object storage is
not mutable so you can't do a pens you
can't do modifications happens that most
Hadoop workloads now just write out new
files think about things like parkade
that works really well with object
storage so if you want to move your
spark job for example to the cloud
you're running on data proc the only
thing you need to do is to basically run
that that job on deta proc and change
the Hastie of fresh prefix with GS and
now suddenly you're able to use the
object storage you're able to get much
better throughput you can have different
workloads looking at the same storage so
you gain some extra benefits there but
there is a slightly hosting again
because you're changing from HDFS to
object storage things like my sequel so
this is that this is slightly you could
kind of say this is a little bit more--
hosting but we're gonna take the
management away so that's where the
difference comes in on you would find
for example your interface for my
support post Chris for cloud sequel is
the same if you were running yourself
but we've taken care of a lot of the
operational part the backups and all
this kind of stuff so the re hosting
part there is doing less work sounds
terrible and the next one is Redis again
it's a very similar kind of thing that
we hosting part is that we're taking
away some of that operational overhead
so coming back to this slide because I
think this is as as they've pointed out
and as it was clear from my examples
there as well this is what makes Google
really special in terms of
structure that network in between within
our data center is 1.3 petabytes
that means a hundred and thirty thousand
machines talking each other talking to
each other at ten gigabits per second
it's like really really fast that means
we can consider storage which is not
local effectively local so whether
you're attaching a disk to a machine or
using object storage or you're reading
data from bigquery you're basically
doing that processing power separate
from where you're storing your data so
multiple workloads looking at the same
data you can see you can scale out the
storage independently from the
processing now to given where this
becomes really concrete is for example
let's say I need to capabilities so I
have some data and I want to make that
data let's say I'm creating
recommendations for people now I have
two use cases one I want to be able to
serve those those recommendations as
fast as possible now I could choose to
have those in memory in memory store I
could choose to have them in a key value
store like BigTable where I've got
random readwrite access and also very
low latency but let's say I have another
use case as well where I want to do
analytics so I want to kind of look at
all the recommendations that I've
actually generated and I want to see how
they're changing over time all this kind
of stuff well in that case it might be
good to have them in columnar storage
because then I can do you know big
massive queries and aggregate things and
just select the column I'm interested in
instead of selecting the whole row of
data so I would store it in bigquery if
you look at clouds you look at the cost
of processing and look at the cost of
storage storage is generally cheaper
than processing so it makes sense to
store this data multiple times now if
your use case is ad hoc you might say
well I don't want that well then
something like bigquery provides
Federation to BigTable if your use case
is I need to run lots and lots of
queries and I want this to be really
fast then you would store it in both
places so then you not student start to
think about how is that pipeline that's
actually provisioning that storage how
can I provision two sets of storage
so in this first one in this big data
analytics use case and we're going to
look at two types of data coming in so
both events so this is kind of streaming
data batch now your processing could be
with beam and data flow it could be
through spark and you're running on data
proc and giving you options here there
are more the point is you can then go
and choose where you store this data as
well so you could be having your batch
and a streaming data coming in you're
processing it and the next thing you're
saying as well I need to serve up
quickly so I will move it across and
make sure it's available in BigTable
that top one in the middle then I need
to run my analytics so you make it
available in bigquery actually there's a
whole bunch of data I just want to
archive because you know I want to see
how it's created later or it's not in a
structured format you would need to
change you know I'd change data types or
clean the data a bit more to get it into
bigquery well then put in Google Cloud
Storage from there if you were going to
query that date so well bigquery is
native so you would have like native
native storage you're querying is going
to be optimal the Federation to the
other types of storage and then from
that you can go and visualize it with a
whole host of different applications as
well all run your models or whatever it
is that you're trying to do then another
example I want to give us like a modern
scalable ecommerce now you can take away
the word e-commerce here and just
basically put any kind of application
that you're trying to scale for like
internet scale this is how we would kind
of approach this it's really kind of
benefits or some of the things that
Google can provide you so for example
I'll click clouds low balancing our load
balancing is global we I mean we get
great latency on that it's it's it will
it will basically allow you to go and
move to to route the traffic to the
right zone you saw earlier in the
presentation today like how many points
of presence we have our CDN so if you've
got data in your bucket which in Google
Cloud Storage and you want to serve that
up on your website you can put our CDN
in front of that so it's caching it on
our edge so we can serve that up to your
customers as quick as possible
and then let's take for example the
other type so the other things that we
might be doing there is having
micro-services or you know running on
kubernetes for example and we might want
to have a back burner like a database a
strong inconsistent database that will
scale with the application could also be
globally available as well so one of the
another point about spanner not only
does it scale horizontally you can also
run this globally that's what we do for
things like Adwords bidding for example
another example like spanner underpinned
so much of what we do if you look at
Google Cloud storage when you use they a
API to list the items in the bucket that
metadata again is storing in spanner
that's a global product just as so if
you go if you run a command and say what
data do I have in this bucket you won't
expect to see any lagging getting that
resource back and you expect see a
consistent result so you could use
something like how span on your own
application and support multiple micro
services and running in multiple zones
the load balancer directing you to the
right mote micro services closest to you
to reduce the latency and having a
strong consistent data model behind that
and you may have things that you want to
put to get even faster to your customer
so spanner will give you you know in the
in the tens or the low tens of
milliseconds of latency maybe you have
things that you want to serve up in your
application even faster than that it's a
sub millisecond you would have user
sessions might be an example you might
have stuff from a product catalog but
you really want to get out as quick as
possible and for that you could use
memory store so hopefully it's very high
level you know architecture you do an
idea just how you would piece some of
these things together so the last thing
before we take questions and I realize
we're running out of time base we will I
will wait outside I'm sure Dave will as
well to answer any questions you have is
OK which storage we've gone for a few
examples we have examples this on the
website and I kind of went all OCD on
the aeroplane over here as you can see
so something like this should only take
an hour to create but when you want to
fit it all on the screen and you move it
from left to right a hundred times then
you know you can cure at least two hours
on a transatlantic flight
but hopefully if you I'll just leave
this up on the screen as we wrap up but
we've talked we've spoken about all of
this today and it's kind of this is not
the definitive answer this is a freight
a guide a decision tree to help you kind
of work out which storage to start
looking at you'll see for example one
storage here BigTable you're seeing in
in multiple places one of the questions
I get asked about BigTable and spanner
is like which one should I use I should
use spanner now because like spanner is
just like BigTable but then you know has
strong consistency over multiple records
well yes it does it has strong
consistency over multiple records at the
multiple tables with that comes a lower
latency a higher latency Wow
so if you need a very low latency and
you were only interested the the row
level you could consider BigTable so
these are the kind of things that you
could think about okay and the rest of
the questions we will take outside so
the next speakers can have the room
[Music]